and sometimes you speak like like you're
from a different time
wait what was their first and last line
first impressions are everything
but last impressions can be just as
important two simple sentences can tell
us a lot about a character
they can encapsulate the character's
journey give us insight on their
personality
or leave us intrigued with 5 movies
spanning over 10 hours in total
it can be hard to remember the exact
lines characters say
from an echo declaration of love to a
snarky remark
let's hear the first and last lines of
these beloved twilight characters
i'd never given much thought to how i
would die but dying in the place of
someone i love
seems like a good way to go bella's
first line states how she has never
thought of her death but how she would
like to die with someone she loves
[Music]
her last line makes good on this
sentiment as she will now spend eternity
with the one she loves
no longer having to think about death
it's a perfect sentiment to end the
series on
there must be something open physics
when we first hear edward speak he is
trying to switch out of biology class in
order to get away from bella
this is in direct contrast to his last
line which is an affirmation of bella
and his eternal love
this shows how far his relationship with
bella has come
from trying to get away to never wanting
to leave bella's side
hi i'm jacob we uh
we used to make mud pies when we were
little when jacob meets bella in the
first movie he reminds her of the time
they used to spend together when they
were younger
he does so with his usual charm and
smile we see the same charm
and smile when he asks edward a rather
unusual question at the end of the
second breaking dawn movie
so should i start calling your dad this
line also shows how edward
went from a bitter enemy to jacob to a
friend he can joke around with
alice is an extremely kind character who
was one of the first cullens to be
really nice and welcoming with bella
hi um are you gonna be riding with us
her first line in twilight shows
justice and she chipperly approaches
bella don't let this kindness fool you
though as alice is an extremely strong
character who grows in her role as a
protector of her friends and family
throughout the series
i've been searching for witnesses of my
own among the tucuna tribes of brazil
we last hear her when she is trying to
find witnesses for the volturi meeting
carlisle was always the level-headed
healer of the group
trying to keep situations as peaceful as
possible this is echoed in his first and
last appearances
i heard the chief's daughter was here we
first hear carlisle speak when he is
checking on bella after the car incident
and his last line of this series is
fittingly one that is speaking against
violence
not today rosalie starts off acting cold
towards bella
as she is afraid of the danger she puts
them in is she even italian
her first line is a snappy remark about
bella's food preferences
but as they spend more time together
their bond becomes stronger than
any of them could have imagined carlisle
needs you her last line shows how she
is now willing to risk her safety for
bella as she is helping to recruit
vampires to fight with them against the
volturi
jasper was the newest vegetarian of the
cullen clan when we met him in twilight
and his nervous delivery of his first
line to bella demonstrates that
it's a pleasure to meet you while it is
very tough for jasper to push down his
urge for human blood
he eventually comes to embrace and
protect the lifestyle their offensive
weapons are too powerful
no one can stand against jane the last
time we hear him he's in doubt of their
abilities to fight the volturi
emmett was always nice to bella but he
was never quite certain about different
aspects about her
her name is bella his first line shows
that he is guessing she is italian based
on her name
uncertain if she actually is and his
last line indicates that he is unsure of
her powers
as he doesn't want to risk getting
painfully shocked i'm good
maybe he should take some time to get to
know bella better
esme is the sweet motherly figure of the
group and her first line is a perfect
example of this as she warmly speaks to
bella
we're making italiano for you she never
changes her ways throughout the series
and is always kind no matter who she's
talking to it's not a people person
her last line states that the vampire
she recruited is not a people person
unlike her charlie is a man of few words
and we wouldn't exactly call him
a wordsmith his first and last lines
perfectly encapsulate his character
hair's longer they're both short odd and
simple phrases said to a loved one and
oddly enough
both lines are four words long woman
knows her trout
sam's first and last lines show a
complete 180 on his friendship with
bella
she's all right his first line is
delivered as he is carrying an
unconscious bella to safety but by the
end of the series
sam is against bella and the cullens she
and jasper crossed our lands to the
ocean last night
his last line mentions how alice and
jasper crossed his territory
arrow is a power hungry vampire obsessed
with other vampires who have special
abilities
and his first and last lines perfectly
reflect this
i'm afraid your particular gifts
are too valuable to destroy his first
line is to edward
when he refuses to kill him because he
is too valuable
his last line is in awe of bella and
alice as he suggests he isn't done
hunting them down
well i'm still dancing when we meet
billy black
he has a friendly remark after bella
tells him he is looking good
he's with his son jacob which is fitting
given how billy is loyal to his family
he supports his son jacob through and
through and his last line defends
jacob's actions
i don't care what he's done he's still
my son
embry has lines that contrast one
another and show the friendship he has
with jacob
when we first meet him he teases jacob
about bella not being his girlfriend
but come the fourth movie embry is now
the one standing up for jacob
against the teasing of paul who's up
paul
victoria is evil and deceitful
throughout her run
what do you want her first line is
mocking one of her victims
while her last line is a cold lie you
know
i love you it's kind of ironic how her
last line is an attempt to get riley to
help her
and keep her alive while her first line
was mocking someone who was also trying
to stay alive
james is an evil cocky villain who never
relents his ways
nice jacket we can see this in both his
first and last lines
you're alone because you're faster than
the others
which are both taunting someone he has
his words turned against him however for
his last line
as edward overpowers him and the cullens
defeat him
maybe if he had a little more humility
he would still be alive
bella's friend group doesn't get much
screen time during the series
but they still leave an impression smile
okay sorry i needed a candidate for the
future angela is nice and friendly
towards bella right from the start
jess she is not pregnant in the end she
is just as nice
as she rejects the rumor from jessica
that bella is getting married because
she is pregnant
speaking of jessica she comes into the
mix in a more passive-aggressive way
she's got a great spike huh she butts in
when she sees mike talking to bella
jessica is always shown to be jealous of
bella and this continues right up to
jessica's final line when she is
delivering a speech at bella and
edward's wedding
edward is all about bella
even though she's not the captain of the
volleyball team
despite the bitterness though their
friendship endures
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding or the
president of the student council
mike newton takes a volleyball to the
head for his entrance into the twilight
universe
he assures her it's no big deal that she
hit him and introduces himself to bella
no no that's that's don't you're uh
isabella right mike can be spotted at
bella's wedding and breaking dawn part 1
checking out the cullen girls what a
gene pool
looks like he's still trying to get a
girl after all this time
bella's mother is very supportive and
bella often turns to her for comfort
hey baby so listen if spring training
goes well we could be moving to florida
they talk on the phone in the first
twilight film which is where renee
delivers her first line about possibly
moving to florida
come the end of the series renee's last
line to bella is a simple yet powerful
one
i love you so much
jane is an extremely loyal foot soldier
to arrow following him without question
arrow sent me to see what was taking so
long her first line is spoken when she
is sent by arrow to fetch bella and
edward
this is when her rivalry with bella
begins as we learn bella is the perfect
foil to jane's torture abilities
it's fitting that her last line is the
simple word she uses to torture people
even if it doesn't work as she planned
leah is a wolf pack member who has
always been loyal to jacob
and her first and last lines reflect
this if you're here to torture jacob
some more feel free to leave
she is first heard making a snappy
remark towards bella about the effect
she is having on him
the last time we hear her is after she
deviated from sam's wolf pack and join
jacob when she makes a short exclamation
in response to asking sam to accept her
back into the pack
what seth is a young member of the wolf
pack who looked up to jacob
his lines are very similar to one
another and even both have him
exclaiming jacob's name
just with opposite tones jake
hey it's about time he got here in his
first line we hear how excited he is to
see his friend jake
and in his last line we hear how he's in
despair that he may have to separate
from him
shake seth never wavered from his
loyalty to jacob
renesme's time in twilight is short
really only appearing in the final
breaking dawn film
but the time she does have is memorable
look a snowflake
the first spoken line she has comes
partway through the movies
when she catches a snowflake and shows
it to bella
[Music]
her last line actually comes in alice's
version of the big battle when she is
writing with jacob
this demonstrates how quickly she is
growing as she is already looking out
for her friends
your isabelle swan the new girl hi i'm
eric the eyes and ears of this place
eric is the first friend to come in
contact with bella he catches her in the
hallway and introduces himself as the
eyes and ears of the school
we see eric is still friends with bella
by the end of the series
as we see him at bella's wedding he
awkwardly reacts to alice when she asks
if the wedding decorations are
too much no no
when you compare a character's first and
last lines you
really get a sense of how far they've
come in their journey
you can spot all the subtle nuances that
make you appreciate all
the hard work that went into creating
these characters who do you think had
the best pair of first and last lines